مروه عليه وما حلته مع الصحيه الان جيده
بحسب حديث اكادر الطبيه الموجود هنا في
مستشفى الملك عبد الله التخصصي في العاصمه
السعوديه الرياض وتحديدا في وزاره التابع
لوزاره الحرس الوطني طبعا هما في تحت
التخدير الان ما زال هذه غرفه همم علي وهو
الان يتم الاشراف علي من قبل كادر الطبي
وكذلك الغرفه المجاوره له
غرفه همم عمر وايضا يتم مراقبه همم حاله
عمر وعلي من خلال الكادر الطبي وكذلك من
خلال التقنيات الحديثه الموفره هنا في
المستشفى ولكن بشكل طبيخ سوف نتحدث مع
الدكتوره هاله العالم وهي استشاريه عنايه
مركزه للاطفال تفضل لنا دكتوره ونتحدث
اليوم عن على الحاله الان لعمر وعلي او
علي وعمر خاصه في ظل وضعهما الان في حاله
التخدير فهمم حاله الطفلين الحمد لله
مستقره همم استلمنا الطفل الطفلين
حوالي ثلاث ساعات
والمؤشرات الحيويه مطمئنه همم اي اختلاف
في المؤشرات الحيويه في اول ثلاثه ساعات
همم تعتبر طبيعيه ومقبوله ويتم التعامل مع
ال- اا ال- الارتفاع دقات القلب او ضغط
همم الدم وكذا عن طريق المراقبه وعن طريق
همم اللي هو تزبيط الادويه المناسبه همم
الاستفاق تمت الحمد لله نعم يعني عندك علي
بدا يتحرك
الان هو بيتحرك لكن ايوه نتعامل مع ال همم
الحاله الان بان احنا نعطي له اللي هو
جرعات مناسبه بحيث انه نرجع وينام لانه
اهم شيء السيطره على الالم وعدم التوتر
طبعا الامر المهم بالنسبه للطفلين علي
وعمر ان العلامات قويه خلال الثلاث ساعات
الماضيه بعد وصولهم الى
غرفته ما هي سليمه وصحيه وجيده وذلك من
خلال التقنيات التي يتم متابعتها والاجهزه
الطبيه الموجوده اضافه الى الكادر الطبيه
الموجود ايضا هنا في مستشفى الملك عبد
الله التخصصي في وزاره الحرس الوطني في
العاصمه السعوديه الرياض